after nearly two weeks of fighting
Sudan's most powerful paramilitary
Patrol the streets of Khartoum field
commanders say their forces control
areas in the southeast of the capital
but it's difficult to verify information
the battle has intensified around
Khartoum airport and is still being
contested by Army and paramilitary
troops and the fight for information has
become just as crucial here the rapid
support forces or rsf says it maintains
its presence I
done to all those listening to any false
rumors that rsf are in control of the
general command or the airport we are
now inside both facilities
but Sudan's Army denies giving up power
as you can see from the green square up
to this point there is nothing but the
Army Personnel they're now combing the
area for rsf Fighters
Army released video celebrating the
surrender of what it says a rapid
support forces fighters in alfreshka
al-sugra in the southeast
[Music]
a general meeting troops in hartum
earlier in the day an airstrike hit
several homes in kalakla south of the
capital Sudan's doctor's committee is
warning of dozens of casualties the
rapid support forces is accusing the
army of directly targeting civilians but
the Army says the rsf troops are hiding
in civilian areas and using people as
human Shields
the conflict has led to a major
humanitarian crisis millions of people
in the capital are trapped in their
homes with power outages no running
water lack of food and an internet
blackout
the chaos has spread two state prisons
where hundreds of inmates from Kobe
National prison have reportedly escaped
others from sorbet prison were captured
by rsf paramilitary troops
while the fighting wages on those who
can are trying to flee several countries
including Italy France Germany and
Jordan are the latest to pull out their
diplomatic staff and foreign Nationals
with no one to rescue them Sudanese
civilians are taking matters into their
own hands to find safety some traveling
by bus to cross into Egypt getting out
of Horton was definitely the most
difficult part of this entire Journey
um having to go through these
checkpoints where you don't know whether
you're going to be robbed or killed or
I'm just uh holding my mother's hands
looking into my grandma's eyes just all
holding each other's hands and praying
that it all goes smoothly there have
been more International and Regional
calls for mediation Ethiopia's prime
minister is appealing for both sides to
talk
I asked my brother al-burhan and my
brother hamidi to stop the fighting
immediately and adopt dialogue but the
two warring sides appear determined to
fight on as Sudan enters a new phase of
war and a deteriorating humanitarian
situation rahila Mohammed Al Jazeera
let's get a live update now with Hema
Morgan she's our correspondent joining
us from Khartoum so Hiba day 10 and
reports of people in the capital going
days without electricity or water as the
fighting really shows no sign of letting
up
yes indeed now some people are trying to
leave the capital along with thousands
of others who've already made their way
either to neighboring states like
Jazeera in the southern in the central
part of the capital or to uh River now
state in the northern part of the
capital but the issue right now comes
down to the issue of financial means
banks have been closed since the start
of the fighting online banking
operations have also been stopped
because many of the banks say that their
facilities have been hit and they've not
been able to allow their staff in
because of fighting ongoing in the
streets and their and safety and fear
for their safety so for many people they
say that they want to leave because the
situation has become untenable with no
running water for 10 days now no
electricity and then there's the issue
of getting Commodities they can't go to
the markets because there is no Market
many of the markets have been burned
down and where there are still standing
prices have increased and again people
don't have the financial means so
they're trying to get out if they can
but they say transport costs and fuel
costs have also more than tripled in
some places gone up to 10 times the
price price so they say that they're
just waiting for this fighting to to end
and they're trying to live with the
situation but many of them say that
they're in desperate need of water
they're in desperate need of electricity
but most of all they're in desperate
need of medical assistance because they
do have people who are injured but
hospitals have gone out of operations
due to ongoing fighting and artillery
strikes on medical facilities okay but
thank you so much Morgan reporting for
us from Khartoum
so as we mentioned fighting north of the
capital has intensified in the last few
days civilians living in Khartoum say
that airstrikes have been launched near
the state broadcasting Center in
umderman fighting has also escalated
between the Army and the rapid support
forces in and around an area of Bahari
joining us on the line from Port Sudan
is
a civil activist who's just arrived from
hartum Dalia Muhammad thanks for
speaking to us can you tell us about
your journey from Khartoum to Port Sudan
uh uh hi thank you for having me
um it literally took us actually 24
hours we left at noon yesterday and we
arrived at 2PM this afternoon in Port
Sudan
um
we try to take the safest route possible
uh uh I have I mean I've traveled around
Sudan but that was the first time I've
seen some of the roads and the
the
the travel path that we took but we made
it and uh what did you see on the way
there yes well we're here so we've got
to see what did you see on the way there
did you encounter anything sorry you
know we only encountered army army
now we only encountered Army convoys and
army outposts you know they've checked
they've come on the bus and they'd ask
are we also the needs you know if
there's any foreigners and where are we
going and they were very civil there was
nothing
undone it was very straightforward that
wishes well and then we just move on but
I think we stopped we were stopped
something like maybe seven to eight
times which is fine
I mean I guess we're in a state where
security is at a high premium so
I mean we all made it in one piece what
about the situation currently in in Port
Sudan do you feel uh completely safe
there
foreign
right now is turning into an evacuation
Hub if I'm not that we caught up with
the United Nations Convoy that was
leaving so our understanding is a lot of
the ngos and new and uh folk are will be
Trump will be leaving from Portugal what
method of travel they'll be using I
don't know that they'll be going by sea
or I've also been told that Port Sudan
airport will be opened to facilitate
those who are traveling or leaving it's
so far it's good it's safe I mean
personal was was in under the Army's
control I think by the first day so it's
pretty safe and it is a port city so
it's more open than you know you know
the trade hasn't stopped and you know
it's mainly cartoon that's that's been
Paralyzed by what's been happening all
the other cities we passed through
gadariff and through Casella we spent
the night there they all seem fine
they're you know functioning as normal
it's only Sudan that's
it's only cartoon that actually hasn't
been it's at a standstill so to speak
right and you got out of cartoon but
obviously I mean you must know a lot of
people that are that are still in
Khartoum some people can get out some
people can't some people want to some
people don't want to these are very
difficult decisions to make I suppose
how how difficult was it for you to make
that decisions
um
it was very difficult to make the
decision because it's never an easy
choice to make to leave your own home
and to leave your city but you reach a
point where you decide what the
probability of danger is higher is it
the higher to stay or is it higher to
leave and we decided we better it's off
we're better off taking the risk of
leaving and you also have to put into
consideration you have elderly or you
have people who need medical care and
staying in cartoon was no longer an
option whatsoever
at the same time uh like I guess when
Supply is high and demand is low the
prices for you know tickets for bus
coach tickets or private car hires shot
up so those who were able to leave
cartoon unfortunately are those who can
afford to do it the vast majority of
students and the vast majority of those
who resist in cartoon can't offer so you
know they have no choice in the matter
they're forced to stay in cartoon
so it's just it's a matter of luck it's
a matter of faith I mean I don't I mean
it's very I still have family members
stuck in cartoon I have family members
stuck at the borders in Egypt I have
family members stuck in other cities in
Sudan but they all have they're all
trying to get out they're all trying to
find the safe way out and
if they can do it those who can't find
something they just hop on the bus or
they hop in the car and they leave right
we really it's it's become a matter of
life for death do you stay or do you
leave that's it we have no other choice
in the matter
we really appreciate your time with us
and Al Jazeera thank you so much